[موسيقى]
الان اصبح واقع اذا ما تستخدمها اليوم انت
تعتبر متاخر او ستصبح متاخر قريبا عن
الناس اللي قاعد تستخدمها شاجي بي تي
عباره عن اداه ذكاء اصطناعي لارج
language اللي هو
نموذج لغه كبير يستطيع ان يعالج المعلومات
بطريقه فذه انا شخصيا لما اروح للمعلومه
اذهب الى الانترنت بعد ذلك بعد بعد ما
اخذها من اذهب الى الانترنت واتاكد من صحه
المعلومه
[موسيقى]
الوظائف المعرضه للخطر او خلينا خليني
اعطيكم اياها بالطريقه اللي طرحت في ورقه
علميه هم لم يقولوا المعرض للخطر بقدر ما
هي معرضه لان تستخدم
كثير من الشركات يعني اي شركه فيها
معلومات
ستتعرض لاستخدام
فالمحاسب ممكن يتاثر الكتابه ممكن يتاثرون
استشاري ممكن يتاثر كل الناس ممكن يتاثرون
اللي عندهم تقديم خدمات فيها تحليل
المعلومات
كتابه او ما شابه ما هي الوظائف اللي لن
تتاثر منها غساله الصحون الزراع قطاعين
الخشب الناس اللي تعمل في الحرف اليدويه
هناك بعض الشركات عندهم ناس رسامين فنانين
هؤلاء الناس اليوم مستائين جدا من الوضع
اللي هم يعيشون فيه لان قلب لهم الساحه
اللي كانوا يعملون فيها من رسم ثنائي
الابعاد وثلاثي الابعاد الى متجرني لصناعه
الكركترز للالعاب الكمبيوتر
وتاثروا بشده الى درجه انهم كانوا يقولون
فقدنا الرغبه بالعمل لان اصبحت المهاره
اللي احنا نحبها ونعشقها بايد الكمبيوتر
ولم نعد نعمل كما نعمل في السابق
حاليا هذه مطروحه من سام اولد وغيره شركه
تطلب ان تكون هناك رقابه من الدوله ان
تكون هناك قوانين لوائح توضع للذكاء
الاصطناعي حتى لا لانه يستخدم بشكل سلبي
او انه يؤثر على الوظائف انا مع استخدامه
ولكن مع تطوير
الجامعات واساليبها في التدريس لان راح
يكون مدرس يوم من الايام اعتقد يجب ان
نستخدم هذا ولا نخاف من التكنولوجيا
بالعكس ان نحاول ان نطور انفسنا انا اعتقد
الحين اللي حاصل ان بعض الجامعات ترفض
استخدامه هذه فتره انتقاليه الان يوقفونا
لفتره معينه الى ان يجدوا حلول للتعامل
معه بطريقه مناسبه وبعد ذلك ينتقلون
لاستخدامه وتصير الامور مرتبطه
[موسيقى]
مليون في المئه نحن في ثوره لم تحصل في
تاريخ البشريه ابدا حتى انا اسمع مقارنات
الثوره الصناعيه ثوره الانترنت انا اعتقد
هذا شيء مختلف تماما يعني خلاص وصلنا الى
الدروه ذروه ذروه
الذروه اللي الانسان يفتخر فيها وهو عقله
يعني خلاص تعدينا مرحله
متفوقه جدا الى درجه ان الان نحن اذا وصل
الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني الى مستوى ان يصبح
عام
عندئذ يعني
طبعا يجب من الان ان نبدا ان نعمل على هذا
الجانب لكن عنده اذن سنشعر بقوه الفائقه
لهذا الكمبيوتر تخيل يعني
بمعلوماته يجيب وكانها استشاري في كل
الحقول
فتخيل معاي كيف راح يكون في المستقبل لما
يكون ايضا اكثر ذكاء وعنده منطق اكبر
ومع تطور الاجهزه والرياضيات والاساليب
الجديده في معالجه هذه الاشياء الذكاء
الاصطناعي بكل تاكيد راح يصل الى مرحله
يتفوق على جميع البشر على الارض
لسنا في خطر من هذا اليوم بكل تاكيد يعني
لكن لكن هذه السيناريوهات تطرح حتى الواحد
يشوف
المدى اللي ممكن تصل له هذا او هذا
الذكاءات الاصطناعيه فاليوم ما في خطر لكن
دائما نحسب حسابنا للمستقبل